Ya
ben lale Laleler ona
bugün sizinle hayat hikayemi paylaşmak
için buradayım Aslında Herkesin bir
hayat hikayesi var Benim de var ama
benimki bir başarı hikayesi değil
benimki daha çok başarılı olmak için
gerekli değişim için Azmin
bu hikayesi
Ya ben 75 yaşındayım
yaşamın ilk 43 senesi
genelde mutlu ama başarısızlıklarla
hatalarla dolu geçti 43 yaşından sonra
ne oldu sizinle onu paylaşacağım Aslında
genel olarak
Azimli bir insan oluşum tutkulu bir
insan oluşum daha iyi bir hayat Biz
istemem merak etmem
değişme açık olmam ve galiba bu 43
yaşından sonra biraz daha başarılı
olmamı sağladı benim 43 yaşından sonra
ha
o neler olduğunu anlatabilmek için dokuz
yaşına geri dönmem gerekiyor o yaşlarda
bir gün bir yaz günü çok sıkıldım her
zaman kitap okumayı çok severdim evde
bir kitap bulurum ümidiyle yüzde bir
kütüphane vardı asıl zengin de bir
kütüphane neydi hatta üstü laflarını
merdivenle çıkıyordu ama annem Amerikalı
olduğu için kitapların çoğu
İngilizce'ydi Babam da mühendis olduğu
için değişik dillerde teknik kitaplar
the bir kitap bulurum diye merdivenleri
tırmandım hiç raflarda bir kitap buldum
bu üzüntü bırak yaşamaya bak
ben tane günün bir kitabı
ona VR çekince ağır geldi Türk de tabi
kitaptı yere düştüm Merdivenlerden aşağı
indim ve yerde açılan sayfaya okumaya
başladım bir hastası bel karnegi ya
şöyle diyordu Altay evvel bana
üzüntülerimi yazmamızı söylemiştiniz
bende yazmıştım Altay sonra okumamı
istemiştiniz okudum Savaş bitti eşim
iyileşti ben iş buldum
haklısınız boşuna Endişelenme şim
Teşekkür ederim hayatıma dokundunuz bu
hayatıma dokunduğunuz
benim hayatımı dokundu böyle bir of gibi
karnına girdi
ve ondan sonra baktığımız zaman bütün
yaşamım boyunca
bu ne yaptıysam İnsanların hayatına
dokunmak için yapmışım
küçükken oldu Bir de 9-10 yaşlarında Ben
evcilik oynamaz dım
Evet Ee un kıtlığı vardı o senelerde
bizim tarafımızda da verir paslı
terazi vardı
inşaatlardan topladım kireçtaşlarının
yapıp Hani onun bulunmuyor ya İnsanların
hayatına dokunacağım ya bakkalcılık
oynardı
Biz de diğer oynadığım bir oyun da o
zamanlar üç yaşında olan kız kardeşimi
karşı motor durumu yanına oyuncak ayı
oyuncak bebeğin vesaire bu öğretmencilik
oynardık tahtada bir şeyler yazardım
Şimdi anlıyorum ki ben seminer veriyor
muşum Uzun lafın kısası dokuz
yaşlarındayken benim
mesleklerin belliydi satıcılık ve
eğitmenlik ben ne oldum kütüphaneci
Neden Çünkü annem bana sen kitap okumayı
seviyorsun üniversitede Onu oku dedi ben
o zamanlar
[Müzik]
yaşamımı Kendimi üretiyordu hep
birilerine soruyordum
bu ne gittim kütüphanecilik okudum dört
sene sonra bir iş buldu
ve bir süre sonra arkamda bir yazı
keşfettim gördüm işi bugüne kadar yazı
şöyleydi susunuz ben ve susmaktan yana
gelecek bir şey değil
düşünüyorsunuz diyor bana yanlış meslek
seçtiğimi gördüm
Ben o zamanlar benim gençliğimde böyle
bir sıra vardı Şimdi artık öyle değil
belki ama benim zamanda işte ilkokul
ortaokul lise liseden sonra üniversiteye
gidersin evlenirsin Ondan sonra çocuğun
doğar sonra sonra sonra gider Ben de
sırayı takip ettim Ve evlendim
en başta çok mutlu olamadım ama öyle
olduğu halde sırayı takip ettim iki
çocuğum oldu
bir süre sonra da eşimin aldığı bir iş
teklifi ile biz Amerika'ya taşındık
başlarda ben mutlu olsak da biz
bir süre sonra yollarımız ayırırsak daha
mutlu olacağımızı gördük ve boşandık
ve ben diline çok hakim olmadığım bir
ülkede iki çocukla kendime hayatın
içinde buldum ve de işsiz Biz Tabii ki
iş ararken ilk önce diplomam olan
kütüphanecilikle başladım ama
kütüphanecilik işi bulamadım çünkü
diplomam geçerli değildi Ben de
Hayalimdeki ilk mesleğe satıcılar girdim
ve bir mağazada tezgahtar olarak işe
başladım çok mutluydum Çünkü insanlara
aradıklarını bularak bulup vererek
yaşamlarından dokunuyordu mama galiba
çok başarılıydım beni bir süre sonra
yönetici yaptılar yönetici ne demek arka
ofise gidiyorsun envanter alıyorsun işte
çalışanların
her şeyi sinir izni ayarlıyorsun Yani
insan ilişkilerinin kopmuştu ve mutsuzdu
Evet Ee yine yanlış bir meslek seçtiğimi
gördüm
satıcılığı Aslında devam etmek istedim
biliyorsunuz buz satıcılıkta çok para
kazanılmaz Ben yöneticilikten ayrılırken
Aslında ailem de hop oturdu hop kalktı
ilk defa para kazanıyorsun dediler niye
değiştiriyorsun Yok ben satışın her
çeşidini denemek istedim ben satışa aşık
bir insandım ve işte sokak sokak gezerek
kapı kapı gezerek Çağla aleti pazarda
adım pazarlarda da çalıştım bir süre
sonra baktım gerçekten benim artık hem
satıcılık olan hem de para getiren bir
ürün bulmam gerekirdi
1990 yılında Amerika'da da ağır bir
ekonomik kriz vardı ve faiz oranları
düşmüştü ve o sene herkes evi olan
herkes lime bu
kredisini yeniden yapılandırıyor du daha
düşük bir
faiz lebende mortgage işine girmeye
karar verdim ama mor geçişini yapabilmem
için altı aylık bir kursu bitirme ve bir
sertlik almam gerekiyordu
Bursa yazıldım bu Sertifikayı Alman da
çok zor olduğunu söylüyorlardı ya
gerçekten zordu Ben Amerika'da hiç ev
almadığım için terimleri anlamıyordum
Hatta hiçbir şey anlamıyordum çok çok
çalıştım gerçekten çok çalıştım ve bir
gün bir telefon aldım telefondaki ses
şöyle diyordu odun nasıl ona tebrik
ederiz
bu testi geçtiniz sert bu kalabilirsiniz
son dakika
ya ben de o kadar başarım olmayı
beklemiyordum ki siz kimi aradınız ben
lale bana evet sizi aradı
o
telefonu kapadıktan sonra
teşekkür ederim dedim Sonra düşündüm
sen anladın değil mi aldım ama 13
verdiğin için teşekkür ederim
ve bu küçük başarı Benim kendime olan
güvenimi çok güçlendirmiş
tiba babam çocukluğumdan beri sen
istersen mutlaka bir şey yaparsın derdi
o seneler
Amerikan televizyonda gece geç saatlerde
Antalya orada mısın bir televizyon
programı vardı içinizdeki devi uyandırın
Ben onu da seyrediyordum ve o zaman
gördüm ki Bu sertıfıka sadece bir
başlangıç ben çok daha fazla şeyler
yapabilirim bu o zaman hayatını
sorgulamaya başladım Ben hayatımdan
memnunum muyum ben daha fazla bir şeyler
yapabilir miyiz
bu yazın ilişkilerin gelişebilir mi
kariyerinden Memnun muyum
bu ve bu araştırmalar başladığı zaman
şimdi anlıyorum ki kişisel gelişimimiz
başlıyor bir adım atıyoruz Bu
araştırmalarım sırasında bir şey aklıma
takıldı
o Herkes çok zeki olduğunu söylüyordu
Peki Benli aptalca şeyler yapıyordum o
zaman şöyle bir şey sordum kendime ben
beni tanıyor muyum ve kendimi tanımaya
karar verdim benim o zamanlar kendimi
tanımayı tanımanın tek yolu benim için
burç burçlar kitabından geçiyordu
dogurmanın bir kitabı vardı onu aldım
balık burcu olduğu için de hemen balık
kadının oldum Aslında o güne kadar ben
her yeni tanıştığım kişiyle V dakika
bile dolmadan Bana balık burcu musun
derlerdi ben de herhalde hassas olduğumu
anladılar
çınardır balık burçları öyle biliyordum
hassastır bunu anladılar beni kırmazlar
diyordum İşte öyle olmadı kılıyorlardı o
zaman sonra Anlı Evet şunu demek
istiyorlardı balık burcu biraz böyle
duygusal falan biraz alıp balık gibi bi
ve
ben de bunun kitabını açtım balık
burcunu okurken de o ilk cümleleri
şöyleydi
Evet beyler şöyle sıraya gelin elimizde
yeteri kadar balık mış olmayabilir
biraz daha okudukça pek de hoşuma
gitmedi ya ben neymişim dinleme özürlü
ümüşüm hep duygularımla karar verilmişim
biliyorsunuz balık burcunun
sembolü iki tane balık ama ters yöne
gidiyorlar beni de bunu şöyle
açıklıyordu birçok insan bu iki balığı
çift karakter olarak yorumluyor Aslında
çift karakter değil bir balık Üstün
zekayı bir Balıkta
duygusallığı temsil ediyor balık kadını
kalan verirken duygularıyla karar verir
ama beynine sormadığı için hata yapar
bir sonraki Çok yakında
o beyni ile halkalar vermeye karar verir
Bu sefer de yüreğine sormak için bir
hata yapar sonra bir geziye bakar uzun
yıllar geçtiğini görür ben mutlu
okuduğumda 43 yaşındayım biraz uzun
zaman geçmiş ve o zaman bu iki balığı
aynı yöne değiştirmeye karar verdim aynı
yöne göndermeye karar verdim ve kişisel
gelişimin başladı çok seminerlere gittim
kitaplar okudum
bazı kitapları anlamadım bazı kitapları
anladım uyguladım ve bir süre sonra ben
de bazı değişiklikler başladı
bu astroloji konusunda çok
en bilgili olan kişiler bile benim
burcumu tahmin etmeye çalışırken 4-5
tane burç ismi söylüyorlardı içinde
balık yoktu o zaman anladım ki ben artık
alıp balık değilim Hatta balık değilim
sonra kendime bir burç ismi uydurdum
ve bütün burçlardan ortaya çalışıp
neden bu kişisel gelişim yolculuğunda
pycell gelişimin gerçek anlamını gördüm
kişisel gelişim olmamız gereken ama
hiçbir zaman olamayacağımız mükemmel bir
insan olmak değil tam tersine kişisel
gelişim özüne dönmek kendin olmak ben
olmak
benim bu yolculuğumda bir çok başka
insan hayatına dokundu bunlardan bir
tanesi kızım
O kızın bana araştırmacı olmayı öğretti
o oğlum Bana kendin olmayı öğretti Doğa
bir öğretti hayvanları sevmeyi öğretti
ve ben olmayı öğretti benim o zamanlar
bu yeğenim bu yüzme yarışlarında
şampiyon oluyordu ondan Hedef sahibi
olmayı ve azimle çalışmaya öğrendim bana
benim hayatıma dokunan dokundukları da
Bu kişiler aslında küçük çocuklardı
sonraki yıllarda o zaman üç yaşında olan
kız kardeşim gittiği seminer notlarını
benimle paylaşmaya başladı ve beni
ne der diye
yöneltti ne der diye merak saldım sonra
ne oldu Sonra Ben Türkiye'ye döndüm 94
yılında iki tane kitap yazdım ettiğim
şemalarla
binlerce kişiye ulaşmaya Anadolu'yu
gezmeye fırsat buldum Bugün de herkesin
olmak istediği yer buradayım de
hissiz kim olursanız olun Eğer değişmek
istiyorsanız değişebilir siniz değişmez
Seniz kendinizi başka bir limanda başka
bir kişilikte de başka insanlarda
buluyorsunuz bunu anlatmak için size bir
anekdot anlatmak istiyorum Adamın biri
bir terziye gitmiş ve bir ceket
diktirmiş eve gelmiş eşine göstermiş Bak
ben bir ceket diktirdim demiş çok güzel
oldu ama Senin kolun Sarp Ödemiş gelmiş
terziye demiş ki benim kolum Sarartıyor
kolay kıvır Bak şimdi satmıyor adam
memnun eve geldi bak demiş yaptırdım
kolumu demiş yaptırdım ama şimdi öteki
kolun sarkıyor demiş terziye yine gelmiş
benim mutluluğum sarkıyor Demir çok
kolay kıvır Bak şimdi hiçbir şeyi
sarmıyor demiş eve gelmiş sarısına
göstermiş karısı güzel ama şimdi artan
sarkıyor demiş o yeniden terziye geldim
benim arkam sarkıyor demiş tercih de ona
demiş ki çok kolay biraz kambur ol
poponu çıkar Bak şimdi 300 bakmıyor
Allah eve doğru giderken karşıdan iki
tane
[Müzik]
arkadaş geçiyormuş birbirlerine demişler
ki ya adama bak ne kadar evde bir ürünü
ama harika bir terzisi var Eğer siz
kendi hayatımızı yön etmezseniz
abone ol
bir hayat sizi yönetir
Abi ben bugün tek bir mesaj vermek
istiyorum
Ya ben yapabilirsem size yapabilirsin
Teşekkür ederim
abone ol